HBO Netflix Amazon Hulu Comedy Central
pornhub and B et he passed on all of
them because he hates money and they
said no first I think I'm autistic but
just like the bad parts of it yeah like
I can't compute numbers or remember
dates but I'll make you feel weird I
just watched a documentary on Petofi
with my friend my friend goes ooh I
could never have sex with a kid they're
so annoying I was like that's it huh we
hate to admit it we've come a long way
like in the 50s we had whites only and
blacks only water fountain which is
incredibly sad especially if you're
thirsty Asian
mark Normand is giving his special to
the people for free because he loves his
fans and nobody would buy it more people
die in America of obesity and starvation
which is like hey we did it I know a
girl she's lactose intolerant still
producing milk she's making something
she can't even tolerate I met a nice
girl in that Jewish app what's that
Jewish app call the Jewish one Pay Pal
mark Normand out to lunch may 12th on
YouTube school shootings what a bummer
huh the great American pastime
don't forget to subscribe
you